there's there's always some Ralphs
willing to suck up to power and
authority but I think a lot of people
are absolutely frustrated and pissed off
at these algorithms controlling our
society that have been absolutely a net
negative not just to the mental health
of this country but when we see the the
mental Warfare that that's being created
out there what are you you're going to
be doing something here what do you mean
by algorithms say it name them well like
like I'm not going to you know bat an
eye when the same huge organization that
labeled me a conspiracy theorist now
won't be able to editorialize I'm not
going to be mad at that it's it's
totally fine let people see what they
want to see it's that simple if they
subscribe to something if they want to
see something let them see it we're
adults here stop treating us like
children I don't want to be recommended
these stupid RV videos or these stupid
truck life videos I don't want to be
recommended some kind of psyop stop with
the psyopsis stop with the nonsense I
want to listen to what I want to listen
to and that's what the people demand and
that's what the people will get